just think that if you follow down the
open the door to anyone who is trans and
will go into the you know the
self-identification side of trans later
on because there are so many different
shades of trans now you're basically
saying that is the end of sport
completely hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Konstantin kisum and this is a show for
you if you're bored with people arguing
on the internet over subjects they know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
broadcaster and stealth styled goddess
India will it be welcome to trigonometry
hello guys thank you so much for
inviting me oh thank you very much for
being it's an absolute pleasure we're
stoked thanks thanks for being here
listen for anyone who doesn't know you
we obviously know everything in value
that's why we're grateful that you're
here tell people who are you what's been
your journey through life how have you
come to be sitting in the chair that
you're sitting in today
well I'm a news reader but my claim to
fame is that I transitioned so I was I
ended up becoming the world's first
transgender news reader that was for
Channel five News which I did for a year
I did Celebrity Big Brother and now I go
on all of the talk shows such as the
loose women good morning Britain with
piers and Susanna and any other show
that will have me really and I talk
about anything though it seems to be
predominantly trans stuff that's the
topic that keeps coming up because
that's the box that I live in yeah well
we've put you right in that box because
that's what we want to talk about but
you're not honestly speaking it's
obviously a big issue right now it's an
issue everyone's such a hot topic yeah
forget about brexit it's all about sex
it
this is the big topic well the country's
transitioning national period yeah
exactly but it has become a big big
issue and and a lot of people will say
it's something that affects a small
small group of people but there are some
repercussions for you know people talk
about women's spaces and all that I'll
get into the reason that you're our
first guest to talk about this and we've
been going for over a year or almost a
year now and we've tried to stay away
from it because it's it's complicated
it's a ask me absolutely that's what
we're gonna do Johnson tippy-toe around
language either just ask me why but it's
it's a point that you're making about
being scared because I'm I'm scared in
the way that I'm terrified I'm gonna say
the wrong thing or enemy I'm sounds
prejudice but you just feared that you
know because you know when you were
brought up there were you were told
there were two genders there were male
and there were female and that's how it
was boys had this women had this and
then you know a few years ago people
thought well there's more than one
gender you're like okay right is it and
then you know there's a pony there's 60
genders and then it will make here's why
we wanted to speak to you because we
never wanted to discuss the trans issue
with any of these screaming loons on
either extreme you know dumb and there
are there are plenty of both and I
remember seeing you on good morning
Britain talking about it in a way that
actually might okay well first of all
this person clearly knows what they're
talking about and also they're coming at
it from a sane angle right so obviously
one of the the crucial points in this
conversation now is the fact that you
have trans women competing in sports
right against cisgender women for anyone
doesn't know cisgender is someone who
was born female and his female right and
you cut what is it beyond that for
anyone who hasn't seen it well well my
view controversially as far as trans
people are concerned
is that I don't think you can actually
get away from the fact that if you've
been through a male puberty the chances
are not guaranteed but the chances are
that you are gonna be taller bigger have
a longer reach a greater strides all of
these elements that will come into play
if you're playing a sport and I would
divide it into two areas the sport I
think obviously in terms of keeping fit
and having fun and recreational then I
don't think there's a problem if
everyone's happy to accommodate people
into that environment then great but I
think there is a distinction when it's
professional sport at the highest level
because to reach you know the Olympic
Games or a national championships in a
particular sport the chances are you're
going to have to have devoted your whole
life to achieving that standard building
up the strength the agility the skill
etc and what we have now we have
transgender athletes on the female side
and who have gone through male puberty
who have been athletes as guys and
they've been sort of middling medium you
know they've been okay and they've may
be finished sort of fifth or sixth but
now that they've moved into the the
women's area you know they're winning
you know they're coming top not
consistently and this is the important
thing to say it doesn't always happen I
think there was one year actually when
Paula Radcliffe was in a pump she was
actually the fastest long-distance
runner in Britain bar none
you know relevant of being female
compared to the man so it doesn't always
work that way but I think there is a
difference and to say as some trans
people such as Rachel McKinnon who's
probably the best-known person and
pushing this argument at the moment for
those who don't know she's a cyclist who
did compete before her transition
and you know finished fifth or sixth I
would say but she's won a couple of
high-profile races since moving into the
the women's side of sports now Rachel's
view is that testosterone has zero
effect on performance and it's the same
with skeletal structure she would argue
that some women can be six foot four
which is true you know I've seen Chinese
basketball players for instance who
tower over everybody else but they are
anomalies and yeah you do get anomalies
just across human kind but I think if
you're gonna have sport and Rachel does
want to keep the distinction between men
and women in sports so she does want
those two separations going off if you
actually argue that testosterone makes
no difference to how you perform as an
athletes or going through a particular
puberty then aren't you really saying
that there's no need to have a male and
female division you're just saying that
we are all the same so why doesn't
Rachel just say instead of saying I need
to compete in the women's division why
doesn't she just argue if that's how she
feels for open sports you know that men
should be competing against women and I
think that's where the little bit of
hypocrisy creeps in with her argument if
she felt that it did make no difference
whatsoever
she'd be quite happy to compete against
the guys yeah and it's also as well if
testosterone made no difference and why
is it on the banned list of substances
yeah well there it there is one
difference in terms of testosterone so
you have your your natural testosterone
that your your body and creates and you
do get instances between the two genders
where they're different
I mean we're sitting here now and if we
had you know some lab technicians in
there's a chance that you could actually
have a higher particular hormone than I
could have we're not necessarily
everybody thinks it's really simple and
that men are full of testosterone and
women are full of estrogen actually
there is an overlapping area like a Venn
diagram where you have the male circle
and the female circle but there is a
crossover in the middle and you can get
just regular guys regular women who are
totally unaware that their body
chemistry is actually on a scale it
could be closer to the opposite sex it
doesn't affect them in any way or they
don't feel they're trans that's just how
they are and probably the best known
case of natural occurring testosterone
in a woman is caster Semenya yeah so but
she's got a disorder she's got a
disorder and it's really important to
say that she's not transgender in any
way this is her natural body that
generates testosterone so caster is an
anomaly in that sense in her sport but
the difference is she's not actually
doing anything to her body and I just
think that if you followed down the open
the door to anyone who is trans and will
go into the you know the
self-identification side of trans later
on because there are so many different
shades of trans now you're basically
saying that is the end of sport
completely because you're going to end
up in a situation where caster Semenya
has to take drugs to lower her natural
you know testosterone in order to
compete against transgender women who
are having to take medication to
actually raise their Eastridge earn and
lower their know thing it just becomes a
drug circus but also the thing with
testosterones is not just about
testosterone right because to start sort
of males but as you say if you go
through puberty you're gonna have a
bigger heart you're gonna have a higher
bone density yeah Bigham all kinds of
it's more to do with the element is it's
going through the male puberty that is
near a crucial thing I actually think
that in the
future because more kids are are talking
about being trans now and you know we're
all more aware and more parents listen
and they get looked after in the future
a lot of kids you know will be
identified as transit earlier on which
might some people might find
controversial in itself but they won't
actually go through in so from in my
case it would have been I wouldn't have
gone through a male puberty so in that
instance in that generation when they
grow up they will be just like a genetic
woman you know they won't have that
growth spurt they won't have all those
changes that tend to happen not
exclusively but tend to happen so in the
future I don't think it's so much of a
problem but at the moment when you're
you're getting people who have grown up
that way and then moving into the
women's division it's a problem it would
be just the same actually just off the
top of my head if you identified
somebody who was really good let's say
at women's rugby at the age of 14 or 15
they had a real aptitude for it a woman
that is yes a natural born woman who had
an aptitude for rugby at the age of 14
or 15 now if you said right for five
years we're gonna douse you in
testosterone we're going to bulk you up
we're going to make you even bigger
stronger etc and then you plunked that
woman back into competing against women
on the rugby Moorish yeah yeah would the
sports allow that or would they say yeah
well hold on a sec yeah yeah yeah you
have actually been doping yeah well it
depends if I play for the Russian rugby
team because in the 70s used you to be
a-- and young whippersnappers you won't
remember those days before the internet
but in those days certainly a lot of the
East European Estate yeah and it was
stay organized it was a program I
remember seeing shot putters office
heavily introduced as hal ger yeah
come on and they were enormous they were
a nation you know very pale skinned
incredible hulks yeah credible so it
does happen and it does oh you know we
can all say that oh well you wouldn't
get that now you know we're better than
that but are we really in sport every
year you somebody in wherever discipline
and wherever sex is exposed as having
used whatever is the currency of the day
to improve that performance the one
question that I wanted to ask
I mean sport is obviously incredibly
important but somebody's not going to
lose their life if they lose 100 meters
race or you know that they don't come
first in the swimming what about combat
sport where you have somebody who was
once a man is now a woman yeah and then
they fight for instance in the female
MMA somebody's life could genuinely be
in danger because that person is going
to be stronger and more powerful just
too before you answer we had one of the
leading evolutionary psychologists in
the world on the show a few weeks ago
Jeffrey Miller and one of the things he
was talking about is actually there's a
difference in how human skulls evolved
so the male skull is designed to take
impact in a way that the female skull he
hasn't so what you're talking about life
and death here yeah well I think that
potentially you could be talking about
life and Jeff absolutely and you are
correct you know about the the bone
structure and the thickness etc if
you've gone through the male puberty the
strength issue I just want to clear that
up University what because if you this
is what why trans is so complicated and
it causes so many arguments I'm going to
read I'm going to give you the simplest
explanation of modern trans as it is now
so you basically have two strands of
trans people you have people who do not
want to go down the medical route yeah
and which is valid you know you're not
hurting everybody you just want to if
you identify it as a particular sex and
you you're happy in your body you don't
have any distress and you want to live
that way then great you're not hurting
anyone I have no objections to that
whatsoever but then on the other strand
you have people who have something
called gender dysphoria which is like a
recognized medical medical condition and
the only way and it's been recognized as
such for the last 50 years and the only
way that the medical community have come
to terms with treating it in the levy
8in it is for people to transition
medically which is the hormones the
surgery etc so you basically change
yourself
as much as you possibly can to be that
particular sex now when people talk
about trans those two things are mixed
up right so when we're talking about
athletes and strength some trans
athletes the ones who have gone down the
medical route such as myself when you're
on hormones actually your male
physiology in terms of muscles and
strength completely goes I actually have
less m-me then a natural woman yeah I
have nothing not really whatsoever
whereas women naturally have a trace I I
now struggle you know big doors all
these things which people say oh well
you know it's just you just plant a
gender stereotype
believe me absolutely honest I get
bottles a pop and sometimes I can't
omen.oh it's just a ridiculous crazy
whereas before it just wasn't an issue
so this the strength in sport when we're
talking about trans applies to some
trans people but not but some people
would say you still have a higher bone
density that's the important thing right
yes so the the advantage which across
the board would apply to both those
cohorts of trans people is the fact that
if you've been through and we're talking
about the male puberty here because you
know I'm not dissing any you know female
to male transpeople out there because
there is no controversy around that no
they don't have a discipline
it's the only reason I'm not talking
about so the on that side of things what
we were talking about there we're
talking about density
oh yeah the bone density stuff like that
so if you've gone through the male
puberty you are gonna have skeletal
why's a difference you know in terms of
thickness length of bones etc which in a
sporting context at the highest level I
think comes into play I feel really
sorry for martina navratilova who got me
a lot of [ __ ] last month for saying
something that was unbelievable it was
durable and you know what I'm really
conscious I have my differences with
certain elements within the trans world
of what is trans and what isn't but
regardless of that I can't abide
anything that's driven by hate yeah or
bigotry you know I'm fine with
discussing or debating actual points and
having an argument but we can still be
friends near the end of it I think
there's a tendency and not just within
the trans world but in life in general
for some people just to take it so
personally can't differentiate between
an argument or a point being made and it
being a personal grudge grudge and I
think with Martina all Martina said it
wasn't driven by hate I mean my god you
know she's like an LGBT icon
she had a trans coach in the 1970s
Rennie Richards
she's been a supporter of trans people
um and all our argument was which is the
same as mine there elite-level there is
a difference and it's not
[Music]
this is it's such a challenging thing to
talk about because like I said I've only
become aware of it in the last couple of
years so would you explain what is it
what is a trans person yeah so just
breaking it right down what does that
mean that term actually mean well I
would have to go back to the stuff
yes the olden days yeah so it used to be
in old money you would have it would be
split into transvestite yeah and then
transsexuals transvestite was
essentially somebody who felt more
comfortable expressing themselves for
generally a shorter period of time as
the sex opposite to who they are
the an who dressed as a woman yeah but
they had no intention and they would be
quite open about that they didn't
actually want to be the opposite sex or
they didn't feel any compulsion to be
the opposite sex in that way whereas
transsexuals which is that's what I am
and you know I have no problem with the
word actually still transsexual is when
you're born with something called gender
dysphoria which is it's almost I could
disconnect you know from the my earliest
memory is just knowing that my body
didn't match up here I wasn't aware of
gender or anything but I just knew it
didn't match you know that something
wasn't quite right and that gate goes
into this whole complicated thing of all
of us used to have had a sex change did
you know that because all babies for the
first six week in the womb are female
that is that is that the template well
we also have a species change so what
happens that the thinking is that with
transsexual people gendered people with
gender dysphoria
that this is something that goes awry so
because
- offers female and obviously you're
getting washed with hormones all the
time and while you're in the womb that
there's some sort of disconnect and
sometimes the brain area doesn't isn't
receptive to certain hormones that it's
getting washed in and which is why you
end up with that the old cliche of the
expression you know my brain doesn't
match not my body so it's a disconnect
and it's a bit like also have you heard
of phantom limb syndrome yes yes yes
absolutely
you know there'll be cases where which
are well documented where people will
lose an arm or a leg in an accident but
they can still feel it and gender
dysphoria is a bit like that your
internal body map sometimes you think
this this it's just not right and it
makes you feel uncomfortable and then at
times it can really get you down and you
know be very distressing so for people
in that situation such as myself I tried
to ignore it and managed to for for a
long time although it bothered me
because I just didn't want to admit it
but for people like that the only
recourse is to go down the medical and
and how long were you did it bother you
for we're talking about 20 years 30
years all my life to differing degrees I
can't remember a single day of my life
prior to transition when I didn't wake
up and literally the first thought in my
head was I'm like I'm in the wrong body
you know I'm a woman I'm a girl but I -
but eventually and I can remember and I
can remember being in primary school and
finding this book we have a little
library and it was full of penguins -
you know the little paper books and
kitties stories and what-have-you and
used to get taken into the library and
you could go in and you would pick a
book and that would be your book for the
week to read and I went and I picked
this book up and it was um it was it was
about fables
he was like Grimm stories of the Grimm
brothers etc I thought oh well that's
like a bright book and it'll be great
and I took it home and when I was
reading this book
I read this story and and it's I think
it's an old norse fable that if you can
kiss your elbow you will turn into a
girl mmm and I can remember at the age
of six already having constantly
constantly had that conflict I thought
this is how I do it this is how I do it
and I spent ages days weeks on it I used
to break my heart on my neck and I can
remember during that period as well when
I went to bed I actually say in a prayer
please let me wake up you know in the
right thing and then waking up in the
morning and having a look and it didn't
have not get quite say you're actually
thinking about it but but that's that's
what it's like when you grow up but then
you reach a stage or at least I did and
you realize it's not going to happen
magically you know Tinkerbell isn't
going to come down do all that and
everything's going to be great so when I
was grow up in the 70s it was even more
taboo than it is now and I knew that my
only reference points for people
anything close to mucking around with
their gender that I would see would be
either a drag queen on the TV which
wasn't like a drag queen now they
weren't glamorous you know a were like
proper blokey blokes but no start with a
stupid wig and they were inviting people
to laugh at them and lock them and that
terrified me because I thought my god
exactly is that what I am is that I'm
going to grow it so it was really scary
so I thought right I'm just gonna buckle
down and this is who I am maybe life
won't be so bad so I'll I'm just gonna
try and switch it off and and try and be
me so then you learn the sort of social
etiquettes and the routines of being a
guy and you know you try and blend in
and nobody notices that you're trying so
much because to them on the outside you
know you look normal this you they can't
see inside how you're feeling so you go
along with that
and you try and fit in and that's that's
what I did but it was always there until
I reached I hit about 40 and I thought I
had it under control in the sense that I
knew it was part of me hmm
but I've never done anything about it
I've never acted on it but then slowly
in my 40s I just started to seize up you
know I lost all interest in like talking
to people or doing things and I had like
a group of guy friends and you know who
we go out you know to have a drink with
the next thing but it was all yeah and I
couldn't do the act anymore I like I
just I go I couldn't do that I just
wanted to be me I just became really
withdrawn and that's when I decided to
transition so getting back to the you
know the definition of trans so I am now
just one type of trans yeah really when
in actual fact new touched on the floor
nice subject which is causing all the
confusion at the moment in the last few
years there's been a real explosion of
different types of I'll call it gender
identity I think is the best way to
describe it which is all great and good
you know I am honestly having been
through something that's caused me
distress myself I think all of us we all
know ourselves better and it's not for
other people to tell us what we are my
only issue and why I fall out with a lot
of you know the trans organizations the
big groups like Stonewall and
what-have-you that a preaching the
narrative and claim to speak for all
trans people is the fact that you can't
put 50
and types of people under one word yeah
and and the the most crystal-clear way I
can give as to why that is a bad idea is
that for somebody like me having grown
up as I did there you know having that
need in me and I've only found any peace
or contentment since I'd transition and
by the way you know since I transitioned
after fifty years I never think about my
gender mmm completely unless somebody
asked me about it which I'm happy to
talk about it's not on my brain whereas
before it was every single day but you
can't have somebody like me with gender
dysphoria transsexual who needs medical
help you know they need doctors they
need to go through the psychology thing
they need the other hormones and you
can't group us alongside the gender
non-binary who say we need to deem Edeka
lies trans because if you D medicalize
trans or tell a government this is what
we want with stonewall and we speak on
behalf of all transgender people and
they want us to do medical D medicalised
trans then where does that leave you
know the current version of me who's six
or seven mm-hmm and has no escape route
you're going to end up with a situate
ooh a government look you don't need to
spend millions on clinics or providing
this particular health care anymore
because now all trans people want is a
form that you fill in and that is all
they want then the government's gonna go
yes fantastic you know the NHS is under
pressure we're gonna save a fortune this
is really easy to do there's it's no
hassle whatsoever but it leaves
transsexual people high and dry you're
going to end up then in a situation when
we're transsexual people who like
everyone else if we have an NHS and
everyone's chipping in the same amount
and they all have different needs and
everyone says their needs are important
you're going to lead transsexual people
unable to act
the type of care that they need
well you know when you're talking about
it though your experience I think there
isn't a human being listening to that
that wouldn't go like I get it yeah I
understand yeah I understand understand
but I I think I understand how terrible
that must be yeah when you don't feel
like you're in your own body and and
then when you do transition how much of
a relief that is because you know yes
I'm talking with you you clearly are
someone who's very comfortable in their
own skin
yeah very clean life right but let me
ask you this I really don't want to have
to ask this question
listen it's it's offensive to something
okay yeah on the fair the way you're
talking about right there are people who
would say isn't gender dysphoria just a
mental health boom you know if you if
your daughter came to you and said you
know daddy I self-identify as a girl
with no arms let's cut my arm off right
most parents would of course wouldn't ya
wouldn't go wouldn't do that so how do
how do we try and understand that and
how do you maybe counter that or what
are your thoughts on that argument let's
say uh well my thoughts on that are
because you know it's not a new thing
that's the other thing that seems to be
very much from critics of trans at the
moment only if you read all the tabloids
and watch certain programs you might get
the impression that they're a secret NHS
convey about somewhere whipping in
five-year-olds and rushing them through
and they're going in as Bob and they're
coming out as Barbara well first of all
we all know that nobody on the NHS gets
any treatment like that secondly doctors
psychologist psychiatrist can you
imagine that if they gave somebody a
child a quick sex change at a young age
and it went wrong no they're going to be
terrified you know so it's it's not like
it's portrayed in to the general public
it is a long drawn-out process and what
the criteria actually is to be diagnosed
this is on the medical side again I've
got I'm sorry I have to keep going over
this distinction no no no different
types of trash so this is for children
you know who in your analogy they're you
who consistently say you know
daddy I think I'm a boy thinking I think
I'm a girl whatever the criteria for the
medical profession is consistent and
persistent which isn't the same as a
fads now if you go through a stage of
being say a tomboy yeah her instance
that might last I don't know a few
months yeah
six months or so but you would still you
you would still be doing other things
this site how we all have questions
about our sexuality normal you know for
all children you know to question who
they are that's a natural healthy thing
but with transsexual people and who have
gender dysphoria we do know right from
the start just as much as you I'm
guessing probably have never questioned
I don't know the way you're probably
never questioned your sex no no ever so
just as much as you're sure that that is
the case in my situation then we we have
that every day you know until it's
resolved we're it's as if you've broken
you you know when you've broken your arm
yeah you know you can feel it you know
it's not right yeah the the thing that I
found actually really quite moving is
the fact that you talking about your
experience and essentially you were
having to live a lie for the majority of
your life and that must be so painful
the knowledge that you can never
actually be yourself at any point and
you are always having to have this mask
on I'm sorry I just no no it was it uses
the first five six years were actually
horrible because I'm New York I knew I
couldn't talk about it yeah - anyone
need the 70s yeah because of that era
and it used to really upset me but then
went up
people say you know how did you learn to
be a woman and they've actually got it
the wrong way round because I can
remember as a kid it was actually
learning to be a guy yeah and and a boy
and I can remember a really young age
just no not having that comfortableness
and so I thought right I'm going to
consciously watch guys you know see how
they interact because all the social
etiquettes are different and again you
know radical feminists would say oh well
that's just learned behavior you know
there is no such thing as gender the
entire gender thing is made at where as
I disagree maybe parts of it a major but
if you look at lots of animal species
you know gender is very very distinct
that the one I always give is the lion
and in in the lion world
it's mrs. lion who actually goes out and
does the hunting yeah and dad stays at
home now that's not because it been to
some pcs you know there is a difference
between the genders and I remember as a
kid looking at boys and thought that's
have got to act and that was the
learning bit that was the hard bit for
me one site even when I you know I'd
spent half my life playing that
character and actually losing myself in
it so much but when it came to the point
you know when I transitioned and I felt
right this I can't do this anymore
this is the last day I pretend to be a
guy I'm not dressing as a guy anymore
I'm just gonna be me soon as I did that
it just everything came you know as I am
now it wasn't like a learned thing at
all there and but there are cases and
what the your case is really you know
inspirational there are cases of people
who when they transition they almost
they think that it's going to solve
their problems but it doesn't that's a
good pipe and you know and then
sometimes they wish to transition back
or there's quite a few cases of people
then going on and realizing this hasn't
solved my problems and then committing
suicide
well could you explain it a little bit
about that yeah well it there's a few
issues there yeah just clarify them up
and the actual D transitioning yeah
rates for transgender people despite
what the papers say are really low I
mean you're talking single percent
figures so 490 I think it's 95 or 96
percent of people who actually
transition in a physical sense yeah
there is no regret there they're cured
if you like you know they they go on to
lead happy fulfilling normalized within
society having jobs raising their
families all those sorts of things and
the reason excuse me I've had a gassy
drink the reason why I'm actually in
favor of keeping trans medicalised hmm
to some degree is that in order to
transition at the moment down the
medical route it's a big decision it is
a one-way ticket so nobody wants to get
it wrong you know the patient wants to
be absolutely sure that this is right
for them and all the professionals doing
the surgery and the work that's involved
with a medical transition they want to
be a hundred percent sure that there's
no kickback now at the moment because
the rates of detransitioning are so
small they're doing a pretty good job
you know during that long drawn-out
vetting period of saying actually this
isn't suitable for you
so we're knocking you out of the line
you're not going to be able to
transition the odd one will get through
because everybody put on a front as well
you know a lot of people can feel
genuinely that they need to transition
but then after going through the
evaluations with the psychologist they
might come to an understanding that
actually this isn't going to make me
happy this isn't the route for me so at
the moment that tends the sister current
system we have at the moment tends to
weed out or identify weed outs wrong
because it sounds as if they're doing it
for bad reasons
I think the current system works in a
good way but all parties concerned to
make sure it's the right decision but if
you go down the self-identity route
which is what is being proposed at the
moment and I do like parts of it but I
really don't like other parts of it
you're gonna do away with all of those
evaluations potentially mmm because it's
a slippery slope
if self-id becomes a system where you
can fill in a form and you can go to
your GP and say I filled in this form
this is my human right transition give
me the drugs and do the surgery and I
don't want any nosey Parker asking any
questions this is what I was got you're
trying your detransitioning routes and
that the level of mistakes is going to
increase it and the backlash from that
is that all the critics who I despise
you know the people who shout bigotry
and hate are all types of trans people
whether they're self-identified or not I
have no time for them whatsoever but
it's just gonna put fuel on their fat
fire they're going to say well here's
the stats yeah you know we now have 25
percent of people saying it's the wrong
things to do
stopall transitioning it's dangerous and
it's putting people at risk I was gonna
ask you about that because you know
listening to your story I imagine and
correct me if I'm wrong that if you
could have transitioned when you were
five you would have done oh definitely
right percent and a lot of people would
say I hear your story I understand that
and yet if my let's say my son or my
daughter came to me and said you you
know we don't let five-year-olds as well
or drive or drink or smoke or do any of
these things and yet this is such a
fundamental decision about that person's
life you'd be worried there Constantine
if you're if you're I don't have
imaginary kids for the purposes of the
podcast your imaginary child if your
kids set up to you quite naturally you
would be worried you would have lots of
questions
I'm sure yeah but if I get it
and just explain what happens when a
child hmm does open up to their parents
how they feel if they if they're good
parents and obviously they don't sort of
lock them in a room I'll put them in a
straitjacket I'll stick them in the
Attic and they go and see a doctor and
the process is something like this
nobody rushes in to any decisions so the
first thing that would happen would be
that the professional the GP and maybe a
psychologist would spend time with the
child it wouldn't be like a heavy chat
it would be as far as the child was
concerned it would just be like a normal
conversation but obviously that
psychologists would be picking up and
certain things then you might get to a
stage where the GP or the psychologist
if they thought it was gender dysphoria
which again is a medical recognised
condition if they thought it was Gd they
would say right what we're going to do
we're going to tread carefully and let's
try some time with keep the life as
normal at school so if it's if it was my
situation for instance you know I would
still go to school as a boy nobody would
know about it whatsoever
but then when you come home you know
spend time as a girl for three hours or
whatever this is with the parental
consent
everyone just acting normal and when you
do that over a period of time they
probably keep a diary for about a year
or so of how you think how you feel
what's your mood all of all of these
symptoms and then they will come to a
decision around the time of puberty so
you know eleven twelve just before it
kicks in and they would look at the
evidence that they haven't that stage
and if you have a child who from the age
of say five to twelve you know just
imagine that for a minute that's seven
years seven years and every day when
they looked at that diary had been
happier
as a girl but when they were a boy they
were unhappy then to me I think that's
enough evidence you know 70 it's not
being a tomboy it's not a phase that you
go through or a fad I think that seven
years I imagine spending seven years in
a jail and that's where it is
effectively it's a prison it's like
being in locked-in syndrome you're
trapped inside and I think personally
some people might disagree I think that
sort of length of time where you have
all of these professionals involved who
are treading very carefully I think it's
the right thing to do because the
professionals are in a very good way
they don't want people to transition and
I don't want people to transition either
it is a last resort it's a really hard
life because of all the stigma nobody
anyone who would want to transition
thinking it's going to be a bed of roses
is wrong
it really isn't when you transition
medically it's something that you have
to do is not choice I tried to fight it
all my life as I've said earlier on I
tried to switch it off and ignore it but
just will not go away because none of us
can run us run away from ourselves and
what advice would you give somebody who
as feels that they have been having this
and they've been you know close at it is
probably the best way is driving right
how would you what would a voice would
you give them if somebody is going
through and feels that they have had
this and they're carrying this burden
yeah well thankfully it's a lot better
now than the 70s and you know there are
resources that you can go to if you go
at the right places online mermaid's is
probably the best charity for children
they give some great advice and just
generally you know find somebody you can
talk to about it don't bottle it up like
I did because it's just horrible you
know and it and it will ultimately
affect you
the downside at the moment is while the
Internet is a good thing having all the
resources if you go to the right sites
and you're careful where you go just be
a little bit careful still sadly about
using Twitter online forums etc it
depends on the individual how strong you
feel as a person I think just being
brutally honest I mean I I'm a confident
person and you know I consider myself
quite strong in that sense but I get so
much [ __ ] on Twitter just for being
trans and basically and sometimes it
doesn't bother me
but then other times like any other
person you know if you've had a shitty
week and then you come on and switch on
your phone and you've got all this abuse
and you haven't actually done anything
odd you know ping you but you get some
idea ranting at you for being you then
it can make you depress you know it can
get you really really down so if you're
if you're a fragile stage and feeling
gender dysphoria uncertain I think the
first port of call is I would have no
hesitation go and see your GP start the
wheels rolling in terms of being
evaluated and the initial stage of the
whole process is talk it will sit with
professionals who will have big
discussions about you and with you and
just find out who you are how are you
how are you going to feel and and come
to a conclusion whether that is the
right thing for you to do
I was gonna if you don't mind I was
gonna ask one of the issues you
discussed on on TV recently was
misgendering right and and that may be
an area of where I I'm someone who
really believes in free speech to the
point where unless someone's insane
violence they shouldn't be able to say
what they were right and that and that's
a sensitive area but before we get to
that there are these tough lemonis these
transmogrifies GE RF yeah that's trans
exclusionary radical feminists and that
they're essentially and if you think in
in in racial terms for instance they're
like the BNP not gender in this they
don't believe trans people are a real
thing what they say to put a crudely and
literally as trans women and again we're
not talking about the men's I don't
think that's not an issue but the route
if you like of the reason that they
don't like trans people is radical
feminists and it's important to
distinguish radical feminists from
everyday feminists because most everyday
feminists are actually on trans women
side they're really welcoming they've
embraced us they're absolutely cool with
it it's the radical wing that have an
issue and the problem that they have is
they're thinking on the subject is the
all gender in a human sense is
completely made up so if you're a
transgender person saying I'm there's
something wrong I I've got this internal
feeling that I'm the other person that
is a complete conflict with what they
believe so the existence of trans people
in a legitimate sense more or less
destroys their argument than all gender
is socially made up because if you
followed their line all transgender
people ever in the world have just been
acting yeah you know I've been putting
on this act so I can go home
get loads of abuse on Twitter oh I'm
having such a good time this is great
you know I've never enjoyed myself
ever before I'm so that that is the the
cutting edge if you like of the conflict
between turfs and trans people but the
other thing they will say is you know
we've created this female only spaces
and now these people are coming in there
and they're you know someone just needs
to say abracadabra I'm I'm a woman now
and they still got a penis and suddenly
they're in the woman's bathroom
yeah woman's risen yeah right yeah a
rapist with the penis in a woman yes
yeah right so those issues I think the
gender construction I get it but on
those is yeah a more practical yeah I'm
gonna try and explain those yeah because
yeah again as with a lot of these things
I agree with some aspects on it and some
I don't um first of all the actual
official stats for the argument that
terse will put forward in that you know
if you allow transgender people women
into the women's bathroom we're all
gonna get beat up we're gonna get
murdered we're gonna get raped well
actually do you know transgender women
have been peeing since time began
let's guess where they've been going
yeah it just hasn't been a public thing
whatsoever
yeah discussion as such there are no
stats whatsoever to say there's been a
spike in the last few years of attacks
on women from transgender people what
you will find is the odd highlighted
case from Ontario or Los Angeles or
Calcutta or wherever they can find one
in the world but that's just about
people you know bad people do bad things
and the actual idea if you sit down and
consciously think about it
even with self-id the rules of self-id
that are being proposed are that you get
the form you fill it in but you then
still have to go to a solicitor who will
rubber-stamp it and you need a witness
and you have to hand in the documents
you know for your old identity etc now
let's just have a hypothetical scenario
here
so I'm a sex pest okay and I have one
name as the old me and I think do you
know what this self ID is gonna help me
reach women I'm gonna pop along to blogs
and blogs the local solicitor here's my
driver license here's my passport my
name from now on is gonna be Mildred and
this is my address great fine there's
your certificate you're a woman
trot off to the local box right you go
in you wait on a woman come in you
attack her the cops get called cops kind
of they come in and you're they're
attacking and you're waving a bit of
paper and says oh I'm a woman I'm
entitled to be here well first of all
the that piece of paper is not going to
stop the cops arresting you but secondly
what license have you got the solicitor
has your name and address they know who
you are you have no protection
whatsoever so on a safety level using
toilets and changing rooms it's not an
issue so in that respect I don't agree
with the turfs argument I think weather
is a distinction and a valid one and I
think people you know ninety nine
percent of the population would agree me
with me on this I think in areas such as
prisons and there's a horrendous case
which I'm probably heard of and somebody
called Karen white and I'm no I'm just
gonna call him as somebody because I
don't even believe it you know
the actual reasons behind her that
person being Karen white were
necessarily legitimate and I think in a
prison scenario if you have some someone
I can't believe the prison authorities
allowed this to happen if you have
someone in a prison for sexual offences
with a male anatomy who decides to
identify as female and adopts female
name name and just for those three
things is then put into the female
estate with women's with women then
you're asking for trouble you know it's
I think it was absolutely outrageous
that that happened so for me
if I was Prime Minister which is a
possibility the three of us we could do
it yeah and I think in fact if I if I
was in charge I think my red line in
terms of prisons would be that if you
had a male anatomy mm-hmm and you were
in for those type of offenses then you
I'm sorry you just don't get to go in
mmm the women's area yeah it just seems
ludicrous to me I think that makes so
much sense and I this is one of the most
illuminating interviews that we've done
we've spoken to over 50 people by now
probably and I think one of the things
that happens online and I think we're
all guilty of it is when we don't know
something or we don't know somebody we
dehumanize them and your theory yeah
Oh trans people are like this or these
people are like that and when when you
come and talk about it and you explain
what it's like what where you're coming
from and also you have a very rational
balanced approach to it I think that
makes such a difference to I think
people on both sides can actually listen
to that and go well you know what yeah
you know let women trans women pee where
they want yeah we'll just protect women
in prison because it just occurred to me
as you're thinking if you were a sex
past and a guy there's nothing really
stopping you from going into a woman's
bathroom in the first yeah a sex pest is
a sex yes whether it's a woman or a man
you know they're there
and again you know certain groups will
bridle at this but there are violent
lesbians out there who will attack women
you know the another common argument
that's put forward recently was about
the fact that the Girl Guides had agreed
to take you know trans girls within
their cohorts that's not a risk you know
the argument was that oh well you can't
have boys sleeping with girls well first
of all they're not boys because if
you've got gender dysphoria you're not
feeling like a boy you know how many
boys would actually dress as it can you
imagine the stick think that girl or six
or seven year old yeah
and when you tell your mom you're
joining the brownies yo no I didn't do
it you just wouldn't have him would it
no I wouldn't have to be really
committed absolutely would remember I
used to get ingrown toe nose in one day
I turned up to school in a pair of
sandals and I just got destroyed other
than that my nickname was Nike Jerusalem
I just remembered that my the entire
exams just got eviscerated and the
thought that somebody would actually
willingly do that um boys are ruthless
and though of that age your life would
be miserable yes as a boy it would be
absolutely terrible yeah so you're not
gonna get a regular boy mmm doing that
and then the other argument that sort of
in my terms
destroys this argument that trans girls
shouldn't be allowed in the the guides
there will be girls in there and again
I'm not saying there it's wrong it's
absolutely natural and perfectly okay
but obviously there will be girls in
that room there are actually attracted
yeah of course to girls know that trans
girl probably isn't attracted so which
one if you're gonna use that argument is
potentially more risky and the
interesting point on that Girl Guides
story as well is that the scouts had
been accepting girls since the 1970s so
it was alright for girls to go into the
scouts and go on camping trips and spend
time away with the boys but it's not
okay
in 2013 for trans girls to go with the
girls
I think we're crazy I think what we can
all learn from this conversation is that
men are far more relaxed and women so
many of my girlfriends and I understand
why I in my old life I never really got
what they were talking about but I
totally get it now and a lot of my
girlfriend's now they also only must
prefer the company
guys it's much better because it's not
this I do think that I love being a
woman obviously I am on Team woman 100%
but I think this is feeling that one
side has it so much better than another
when again the truth is believe me there
are bits of [ __ ] on both sides yeah no
team has it easy they're just different
crap bits I'm sure I'm the crap bit
about being a woman is it's a different
sort I think with guys if guys don't
like you or I have an issue you do a
podcast together you'll sort of have it
out and then that would be the area and
it's like really simple to understand
where I'm no woman side is so much more
complicated the lower you can be
speaking to someone who's got the
sweetest smile on their face and you
have no idea yeah what is going in so
that is that difficulty we like to end
every episode of chicken you see what
I'm saying before we started the show
India it's been absolutely you know it's
been one of the one of the most
eye-opening interviews we've done and I
think just to humanize everybody on all
these sides and to bring people together
that yeah one of the reasons that we
started the show we wanted to detoxify
the whole conversation about in every
issue that we're talking about yeah I
think that's a really good thing and
just the last thing that I would say is
that I think trans people generally
across the major at the moment that
they're seen as caricatures yeah cartoon
figures they have one role and in a TV
sense you know for me for instance you
know even though I've been a journalist
for like 30 40 years talking about every
topic Under the Sun there is only one
box in a media frame even now for trans
people and that is to go on an argue for
your eggs
distance or if you're an actor
invariably you know you'll end up
playing a prostitute or a dead body on a
mortuary slab because we've cornered the
market in those roles and that is all
that exists and I think when we get to a
stage that just normal life and normal
visible things on the TV radio and
newspapers they just show trans people
doing stuff but they don't refer to the
trans hmm aspect that's when we get past
it I did something yesterday this
interview with the paper and the intro
was and it was there it was transgender
journalist India will be I don't think
why is it I just don't Gary it you know
yeah why do you have to put the
transgender no bit in yeah I could talk
about it yeah I agree with it might be
Alan enter of course not of course not
but in our defense because we've what I
was gonna say is in our defense I think
it's an issue that is not understood
well yeah yeah I get that so when we do
someone who's interesting articular
Garrett you know do they know how to
talk about these issues that we can
speak to it's a rarity yeah which is why
when we talk to you it's about that
issue that's not to say that there isn't
other great work that you do of course
but listen before we let you go and
thank you so much for coming on so a
pleasure what is the one thing that
we're not talking about the we as a
society ought to be talking about it can
be related to the trans thing or this is
your one chance to break out of the box
if you want to and I think for me it's
pavement etiquette hmm I think it's a
real problem you know people have
particularly in London cuz obviously I'm
from up north and I'm coming down here
and I can't believe cockneys how do you
all do it people walk around in London
and if you're walking head-on to someone
they will not budge yeah
you must get nose to nose and it's like
the chicken run they're not getting out
of the way
but when you end up moving away and then
you get this ridiculous thing where
people have like their earphones on
their heads down they're texting like
absolved all responsibility for having a
crash a paper an accident and they're
walking and now responsibility goes on
you so you have to
keep your wits around you see these
lemons I'm quite I'm South London so
when I see that by just ten slits left
show I just tends it and then when they
hit they bounce off that's what I do
this is how you know India's a very
special she's managed to find a cockney
all they self-identifies call me all in
Essex where they belong
Essex yeah Russians yeah Russians yeah
I've never liked it because yes well and
so this offend events well listen thank
you so much for coming on you're on
Twitter
you're quite active on there tell
everybody your Twitter handle yeah it's
I think it's you know what I'm not sure
I think it's India will it be well we'll
put it into you and where else talk of
where else can people find your
broadcasting your work other things
where can we find stuff well I I crop up
all over the places be honest you know I
often crop her probably like once or
twice a month on good morning Britain
with piers and Susanna do a lot of stuff
on took radio as well with the Matthew
Wright show and with Kevin O'Sullivan
the TV critic and just about any daytime
program there's a chance that I'll be
cropping up at some stage pretty well
although India on Twitter as always
follow us at trigger pod on all the
social media subscribe to the YouTube
channel if you're not already a fan boy
or fangirl click the Bell by gender
non-binary no stop being Russian bases
this is why breaks it needs to happen
supported follow us on all the social
media click the bell button next to
subscribe button subscribe on YouTube
leave us an iTunes review you can listen
to the podcast as many of you know as
well as watching it here
YouTube and we will see you in the week
from now with another brilliant episode
absolutely and also guys please checked
a bit see if you've been unsubscribed if
you have please subscribe again let us
know and we'll try and do something
about it but once again thanks for
listening we really appreciate it and
see you next week one old Francis wants
unity because he's been taken away see
you later guys bye
[Music]